le leader autoproclamé du président du
venezuela juan guido est en quête de
soutiens après la colombie après la
belgique après la grande bretagne ou
encore la suisse celui qui s'était
autoproclamé face à nicholas maduro il
ya un an poursuit donc sa tournée
internationale il a été reçu cet après
midi par emmanuel macron en personne à
l'elysée
un peu plus tôt il avait rencontré le
ministre des affaires étrangères jean
yves le drian
voyez les précisions de notre reporter
nadège avait razal depuis la maison de
l'amérique latine ce soir à paris 3 nov
de visite en france le président
autoproclamé par intérim du venezuela a
été reçu à l'elysée par emmanuel macron
ensemble les deux hommes ont évoqué le
processus électoral à mettre en place
au venezuela une rencontre dont se
satisfait trois noyés d'eau qui appelle
la communauté internationale a réitéré
son soutien
nous travaillons pour organiser une
élection présidentielle vraiment libres
dans notre pays et il faut une pression
internationale pour qu'une dictature
s'approche d'une solution elle ne va pas
le faire volontairement malheureusement
nous avons essayé l'année dernière par
le biais d'une médiation
malheureusement cela n'a pas réussi et
c'est regrettable car aujourd'hui il y a
cinq millions de migrants après son
entretien avec emmanuel macron juan
garrido a s'est rendu à la maison de
l'amérique latine pour une rencontre
avec la communauté vénézuélienne une
arrivé ici un peu mouvementée pour le
président autoproclamé par intérim du
venezuela puisqu'il a dû essuyer un tir
il a été chahuté par de nombreux
manifestants pro maduro pour ces
manifestants cette tournée européenne de
roanne guido est tout simplement une
honte pour lui c'est très important
parce que autant
on dénonce macron autant ben macron ne
reconnaît pas nicolas maduro
donc ça ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'à un moment donné ben voilà là
la france choisit ses alliés de
circonstance quand les intérêts sont en
jeu
et puis on soutient un dictateur dont
quelques uns qui se tord proclame
président par contre on va empêcher le
peuple ici de s'exprimer c'est pour ça
qu'on a toujours soutenu gouvernement de
nicolas maduro la de la possession des
états unis qui sont toujours entre
d'influencé pour les mettre des coups
d'état et aux ados et s'est autoproclamé
président même chez lui
aujourd'hui plus personne ne le
reconnaît et c'est une honte que la
france le reçoivent de cette manière là
il n'a aucune légitimité pour venir ici
et c'est pour ça qu'on manifeste et je
trouve que c'est inadmissible c'est
qu'ils ont fait l'interdiction de
complices être devant ces gens là pour
leur dire merde non désolé deux des
hommes mais je ne suis pas d'accord du
tout c'est honteux
on défend les trouillon le monde à
l'envers
voilà un an après s'être autoproclamé
président par intérim du venezuela juan
wildau n'a pas réussi à renverser
nicolás maduro et il est en train de
perdre la seule institution qui lui
était jusqu'ici acquise l'assemblée
nationale pour cause un luis parlera lui
aussi député de l'opposition revendique
depuis le 5 janvier le perchoir de
l'assemblée nationale
elle les appelle à manifester de roanne
guido sont restés comme lettre morte
depuis le 5 janvier une année 2020 qui
s'annonce donc compliquée pourquoi noyés
d'eau